dank ich kannte uns gleich als böses tun
und sagen kaufen sich alles in allem ein
neues bundes das böse ist sage ich jetzt
aber nicht ob das haben jedenfalls
meinen vortrag dem ich jetzt heute
halten werden bei der ausführung über
philosophie des opfers und der
philosophie ist aus meiner befassung mit
dem bösen mit dem problems gewesen da
vorgegangen
ich möchte es auch nicht alles dort
wiedergeben was ich dort gesagt habe ich
möchte einen neuen gedanken machen hin
ist er dankbar dass ich hier heute
gelegenheit haben ein bisschen was
drüber zu sagen also man kann sich jetzt
fragen kann der horror also der
schrecken dasjenige was ich gar nicht
unsere vernunft entzieht kann der
überhaupt philosophisch zum gegenstand
einer erörterung gemacht werden ist es
nicht so wie man auch manchmal böse sagt
das lösen ist das unvernünftige das böse
das wenige was nicht sein soll
er ist dasjenige wohne heimlich ist
reichen wollen kann man da nicht sagen
dass ich solche phänomene wie das böse
wieder auf unseren begriffen entschieden
also das ist praktisch nur die effektive
zustimmte sind die sich nicht in ein
system passen lassen also kann es
überhaupt eine theorie des bösen geben
ich bin dass geht beim schrecken beim
grauenvollen ist es noch viel
schwieriger
ob es da von der theorie geben kann da
man überhaupt philosophisch sinnvoll
darüber reden kann und ich habe mal
diesen opa katalog dieser sehr gut
bestückte bibliothek vor ein paar tagen
durchsucht durch frau stand nach
philosophie des horror und ich bin nicht
für mich geworden also also schon so
vieles was gibt es noch nicht ist nicht
geschrieben worden
das kann damit zusammenhängen dass man
gar keine philosophie das haus
vielleicht schreiben kann
mit diesem problem will ich mich jetzt
im nächsten minuten bisschen befassen
ich setze da ran beim bösen langen sie
kennen alle ruhiger safranski rüdiger
safranski sagt in seinem buch als dieser
philosophie schriftsteller rüdiger
safranski da sein wo das böse das drama
der freiheit ich zitiere mal das böse
gehören nicht zu den themen den mann mit
einer these oder an der problemlösung
bei kommen könnte sagt er
er geht noch weiter und sagt das böse
ist kein begriff sein ein name für das
bedrohliche das dem freien bewusstsein
begegnen und verein getan werden kann um
so schwieriger ist es mit dem phänomen
des horrors können wir das überhaupt
begrifflich fassen ich möchte jetzt
anhand von texten beide schelling die
tierfiguren bei der geilen versuchen zu
zeigen dass man sich diesem phänomen des
horrors durchaus an ihren kann um seine
philosophie das bild des bösen und des
horrors herausgekommen das bleibt offen
das bezweifle ich habe ich möchte dass
man so ein bisschen diesen weg
nachzeichnen der bei schelling beginnt
mich meine und bei chicken ändert und
der bei galleon darin seien
schauergeschichten sich sehr sehr
eindrucksvoll findet was ist denn
eigentlich horror gläser einfach meine
definition vor was befindet ist eine
gattung der phantastik in der
infektionen das unmögliche in einer welt
möglich und real wird die der unseren
weitgehend leicht und wo menschen die
uns ebenfalls gleichen auf diese
anzeichen der brüchigkeit ihrer
mit grauen reagieren also euro ist das
hingeht was uns entsetzt was alle
ordnung orientierung zerstört was uns
den boden unter den füßen wegzieht und
wie können wir dann darüber nachdenken
ja jetzt gibt es natürlich einige
zentrale ästhetische charakterisierung
des reports und ich habe den namen
genannt das ist etwa ein baum
ich glaube dass ich in seinem werk vor
allem in seiner kurzgeschichte ich weiß
nicht ob es die canon der titel ist die
deutsche übersetzung heißt der alb der
pervers haid englischer titel die im oft
per gehörs da wird das oeser und terror
als etwas paradoxes dargestellt und als
perversität bezeichnet also die aura und
das böse ist nichts was ein mangel ist
in erster linie als etwas was ein
defizit er ist so etwas was so eine
eigene wesenheit besitzt die man weiter
analysieren kann zumindest ästhetisch
beschreiben kann
und er sagt jetzt in dieser geschichte
über den alb der parasite lesern ist bis
in den usa vor
das sagt er bei der erforschung der
neigung und triebe der prima mobilia der
mensch und ziele haben die psychologen
stets einnahmen übergangen der wohl eher
sichtbar und deutlich als erstes
ursprüngliches nur auf sich selbst
zurück zu führen das gefühl vorhanden
ist
auch von dem moralisten ihren vorgängern
übersehen wurde
wie alle wir alle haben ihn durch die
törichte anmaßung unseres verstandes und
aufmerksam gemacht wie beachtet ja
selbst der möglichkeit gedanken ist uns
nie gekommen weil wir das bedürfnis
fühlten die tatsache je nach neigung
jenes haus festzustellen
eine interaktion aproz theorie wird die
psychologen zu der einsicht gebracht
haben dass sie als ein primitives
prinzip menschlichen
ein paradoxes etwas und das scheint dem
müssten dass wir in ermangelung eines
charakteristischen ausdrucks mit dem
bösen krankhaften kurz mit diversität
zeichnet meinem sinne ist sie der tat
eine mobile ohne motiv ein nicht
motiviertes mutti unter ihrem einfluss
handeln wir ohne verständlichen zweck
oder sollte man dies war ein widerspruch
im ausdruck halten wir handeln aus dem
konnte weil wir nicht haben sollte
in meines lebens ebenso gewiss wie der
richtigkeit der behauptung dass das böse
das sündhafte das schädliche irgendeiner
handlung oft die unwiderstehlich macht
ist sie uns zwingt an 1 winken dieselbe
zu beginn und dieser zügellose haben das
böse und des bösen pferden zu tun
spottet die analyse jeder auflösung
tiefer liegende elemente ist ein
radikaler primäre elementare bekommt das
ist jetzt der starke thesen bei wenn sie
mal zb kannte lesen kann es hat in
seiner philosophie das böse um des bösen
zu tun oder wie man sich das beim
auffinden vorstellt also böse liegt der
freude hat dass dies widersprüchlich das
kann nur ein teuflisches wie sie kommen
für den menschen ist etwas völlig
ausgeschlossen kann sagt auch eine
boshafte vernunft also gründe zum bösen
des bösen und des bösen willen zu tun
das ist für den menschen nicht
angemessen es passt und er versucht
jetzt auf ästhetische und ästhetischer
ebene so ein phänomen dass er das
perverse nennt liegend wie anschaulich
zu machen das kann in seiner theorie
völlig ausgeschlossen hatte und ich
möchte jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter
gehen und zeigen dass der versuch dieses
nach kant begrifflich würde somit nicht
zu fassende phänomen des orange schränkt
uns aber auch dass radikalen lösen dass
das eigentlich schon anklingen bei
schädigen zu finden ist schilling hat
das schon
passieren und zwar gibt es eine sehr
interessante vergleich stellen zu retten
gerne beschreibt angesichts dieses
handelns zum bösen dieses diversen
beweggrund ist den da glaubt aufzuzeigen
schreibt er folgendes und das war soll
sich genauer zu gemüte führen sagt
nämlich angesichts dieses geistes der
pervers hat die stadt in den schlund ist
wenn uns übel und schwindlig und
trainierst bewegung war vor der dv
zurück zu reichen unerklärlicherweise
bleiben wir allmählich verschmelzen
unser übel befinden unser schwinde
unsere angst in ein gebel haft ist licht
zumindest das gefühl hautnah unbemerkt
war nimmt der nebel gestalt an
wie sich aus dem wäldchen muss jener
bekannten flasche in 1001 nacht der
geist bildet auch aus unserer rolle die
am rand des abgrunds bildet sich und
wird immer greifbar eine gestalt die
hundertmal schreckhafte ist als
irgendein dem wohn oder geister haben
und doch ist es nur ein gedanke der das
mag in unseren gebeinen gefrieren macht
und mit höchster in dieser kommen
schüttet wir prüfen soll und welche
handlungsweisen zu finden wir das eins
und allein dem geiste perversität
entstand
wir beginnen die selbe nur weil wir
führen dass wir sie nicht begehen
sollten darüber hinaus oder dahinter
fehlt jeder bewegt kommt also was wir
jetzt hier sehen ist scheint so ein
phänomen ausgemacht zu haben das
phänomen des haus des schreckens und er
bringt das mit einem schwindelgefühl
verbindung den abgrund verdiente stehen
die kann man sich jetzt diesen abgrund
genauer vorstellen ich bin der meinung
dass man es über den begriff der
freiheit tun könnte also das ist der
abgrund eines verwandten zu handeln
sie tun es zum glück den allerwenigsten
fällen aber wir könnten es lägen das ist
die möglichkeit und diese möglichkeit
böse zu haben aus freien vollzug
die erscheint uns zumindest nach peru in
literarischer
als ein amt also die gründe zum bösen
die gründe des schrecklichen sind gründe
sind abgründe dieser weise gewissermaßen
vor den uns schwindelig
deswegen so viel um den schwindel weil
wir diesen schwinde in diesem
zusammenhang diese schwindelgefühl den
abgrund schon bei friedrich wilhelm
joseph schelling finden der etwas vor
es seien untersuchungen über das wesen
der menschlichen freiheit eigentlich was
ganz wenige geschrieben hat ich lese es
mal vor es geht also und willens gering
und der wille es geht und in die
individuelle entscheidung des objektes
sagt dazu der wille des grundes besteht
darin alles zu partikularen oder
kreatürliche zu machen das ist ja wieder
des einzels er will die ungleichheit
allein damit die gleichheit sich und ihm
selbst empfindlich werden darum hergeht
er notwendig gegen die freiheit als das
über kreatürliche und weckt in mir die
lust zum kreatürliche und jetzt kommt
wie den welchen auf einem hohen und
jedem gipfel schwinden erfasst gleichsam
eine geheimnis stimme zu rufen scheint
dass er herr abstürze oder wieder eine
alp fahren unwiderstehlicher
sirenengesang aktive schalten und den
hindurch schützenden in den strudel zu
ziehen
schon an sich scheint die verbindung des
allgemeinwohls mit einem besonderen
werden im menschen ein widerspruch
dessen vereinigung spielen wenn nicht
unmöglich ist es kommt der zweite
wichtige begriffe nachdem schwindeln die
angst des lebens seiner geselligen
treiben den menschen aus dem zentrum das
er geschaffen worden
denn dieses als das lauteste wesen aus
wie das ist für jeden besonderen will
verzehrenden feuer um in ihm leben zu
können
wo ist der mensch aller eigenheit
absterben deshalb seien fast notwendiger
versuches aus diesem in die peripherie
herauszutreten und da eine hohe seiner
selbst zeit zusammen
also wir sehen beschädigen gibt es eine
schreibung dieses falles des bösen des
horrors damit schwinde mit abgründigkeit
und auch mit angst vor notiert wird
das sind jetzt keine richtigen
philosophischen begriffen aber ist sie
und versuche diesem phänomen was sich in
unserer wirklichkeit immer wieder zeit
irgendwie gerecht zu werden und das hat
natürlich auch schon welche prodan in
seiner politischen sind kurzgeschichten
versucht zu zeigen anhand einer
geschichte die sie vielleicht kenne
black cat der schwarze karte er wird
schreibt darin beschreibt darin wie ein
eigentlicher häuser der familienvater
einem geist der perversität diesen
kontinent erlebt und seine katze seine
lieblings katze grausam getötet aus
eigentlich gar keinen grund der einblick
einige gründe ist weil es bösen und
dieses phänomen beschreibt bauer als
geiste perversität ich komme jetzt zu
einem weiteren denkern der auch noch
sehr zentrales in dieser hinsicht und
das ist sören hier gegangen
öffentliche gekommen hat einige jahre
später eine schrift verfasst die heißt
der begriff angst und auch hier finden
wir beide begriffe angst und schwindeln
in einer ganz engen philosophischen
beziehung ist dazu auch ein zitat vor
das hat angst lässt sich mit schwindel
vergleichen kommt jemand dahin dass ein
augen eine gerne tiefer hinunter sieht
so wird ihm schwindlig aber was ist der
grund es ist ebenso es ja sein auge
wieder haben kommt denn gesetzt
er hätte nicht hinunter geschneit so ist
die angst der schwindel der freiheit der
auf kommt der geist die synthese setzen
will und die freiheit in ihrem eigen
die möglichkeit der mutter gibt und dann
die endlichkeit ergreift und sich daran
festzuhalten
in diesem schwindel sieht die freiheit
hier wir sehen also es gibt im ausland
von kant der strecken hat ich glaube aus
guten gründen dass wir das böse oder
noch gravierender das schreckliche dass
wir das begrifflich fassen können das
scheint einfach nicht möglich zu sein da
eine theorie eine regatta system des
bösen system das haus bietet das da
würde ich kann zustimmen es gibt aber im
ausgang von kant verschiedene versuche
mich ohne grund in der romantik bei
schädigung aber auch bei diesem phänomen
irgendwie philosophischen weitesten
sinne gerecht zu werden und wir sehen
hier kommen plötzlich emotionen ins
spiel
subjektive zustände metaphern der
schwindel der abgrund die versuchen
dieses phänomen zu fassen
ich komme damit zum schluss und meine
these wäre die eine philosophie des
horrors lässt sich nicht schreiben das
ist in meinen augen aus begrifflichen
gründen ausgeschlossen
man könnte jetzt sagen die philosophie
des hauses ist der horror der
philosophie also an dem versuchten den
philosophisch zu fassen an diesem
scheitern den versuch an diesem versuch
leidet die philosophie
das bereitet ihr großen schrecken großes
setzen weil es doch die realität ist des
bösen aber auch der schrecken
wir sehen uns keine wahl ich ja von uns
sehen sich gerne auch aus baden es gibt
auch die krimis wir wissen ja nicht nur
ein ausweg denken aber das böse
der horror fasziniert uns und die
herausforderung für eine philosophie
theorie muss sein diesem phänomen
gerecht zu werden ohne ins jeden preis
in dem sinn so interpretieren dass es
gute gründe wären die zumeist führen
oder zu bauen
aber dass es dann irgendwelche gründe
sind motive die menschen dazu bringen
können böses oder sogar schreckliches
zustande zu bringen
der bezugspunkt ist dabei die freiheit
der menschen freiheitlichen eine
abgründigkeit hat die frage bleibt
jedenfalls glaube ich und das ist auch
der grund warum es hier in diesem
katalog diese sehr gut sortierten
philosophische bibliothek ein buch
darüber gibt diese dieses problem bleibt
dann oft das problem wir können ihm uns
ihm vielleicht ein analoges über bilder
über metaphern annähern aber begrifflich
bleibt der euro viel lob für die
philosophie einen sarg um vielleicht
sogar auch ein schlimmer
[Applaus]